hello freak [ __ ] because it was live
and there was hundreds of thousand I did
ring break in 2004 an MTV okay right
when it was sort of like oh well alright
yeah and and we did it and it was
Hawaiian tropics or the biggest thing in
the world all the girls and Fabio was
there and Jon Lovitz was there Vince
Neil was there Kennison was there Rodney
Dangerfield was there and Donald Trump
was there and because Donald Trump used
to go to the Hawaiian Hawaiian Tropic
parties at Ron rice used to throw after
you know the spring break things and
Donald Trump was I knew him back then so
and then I saw him probably about a
couple times at the Playboy Mansion the
last time I saw him at the Playboy
Mansion I think was about four years ago
and he was just there just hanging just
hanging like Bill Maher you know what I
mean like still mark you know just
[ __ ] hang it was it was actually in
the afternoon and I think it was like a
Sunday Funday thing or it was like some
like Easter egg night day or some [ __ ]
and he was just buzzing around and in a
suit and just talking to girls and one
you know yeah him and OJ you know Oh Oh
Jay Oh Jay will be out too I know a nut
Bazaar so what what is Donald Trump like
when you're hanging around with him he
just likes vagina
you didn't mean like he just like us you
know like you know he look at those
babes or you know it was always like
right and that's why anyone go to the
Playboy Mansion because they like vagina
right and we were lucky to get into the
Playboy Mansion we were very fortunate
you only need to get in there and but it
was but so you know and I was actually
talking to Kelly in Conway about right
before Trump got elected on email and
I'm supposed to have dinner with her and
some of her friends but I had to go do
some shows in West Palm at the improv so
I had a cancel out oh you're gonna talk
to Jillian Conway about it who cares
just to be there of course I'm weird in
a hilarious
I wanted that you know you mean for sure
but she was cool we were on I have her
email everyone from
in itself Wow yeah you should get her on
your show will you put on your show oh
yeah I would definitely talk to her yeah
does it feel weird though to be
connected to them now - they're actually
in yeah once yeah once she got once they
got in and I started to see all that
stuff that was going on I kind of like
backed off and I was like you don't I
mean yeah I didn't want to really be you
know yeah but I want to be the vagina
coordinator for him hmm that was more
than either like hooks it up
yeah and vagina can't be public about
they can't talk about it so if you talk
about you're gonna [ __ ] it up for him oh
that's true right now you [ __ ] it up for
him okay it's just a bit folks
yeah we're just not real politics
playing but how great would that be the
idea is is that he's got the trump plane
right you know the Trump plane is
sitting there it was not it where's it
sitting somewhere hmm right where is a
plane it's got to be sitting in like Ana
tarmac somewhere I want him to let me
borrow it so I can pick up vagina from
in the middle and the girl Midwest is
the move well you had the people that
voted for him oh they're happy for him
yeah that how the flower states bring
some you know one-tooth wonders bring
him bring in the dog cuz dude he hasn't
gotten anything think about it but he's
been like cut off cut range hundred
percent do you think so
under success there's like a basement
that they have in the White House there
is no way he's getting vagina but so
none of them do you think none of the
president's like with modern presidents
like I guess like Bush on right Bush
Obama now Trump there's no way they can
right I don't think so
clean kind of [ __ ] it up everybody it
up yeah who is it Linda Tripp sofa lady
Ratatat Monica Lewinsky girl out her
poor girl I feel more bad for her than
anybody like she was she doing an
article about her were that she said the
shame sticks to you like tar over cream
managing poor public's 20 years old at
this point
guess she's got it right you know what I
mean yeah but so what does Trump like
those he and a good guy to talk to like
what did he like obviously he had he
didn't want to run for president back
yeah I think he had been wanting them if
you look at clips now you see a lot of
clips or he
where they interview him and now about
like he find clips in the 90s where they
always say was it the guy from I forgot
that one show on MSN but Tim something I
don't know he died but he says well if
you were present that uh oh yeah Meet
the Press yeah a friend that yeah yeah
yeah actually I was watching that today
while he was talking about North Korea
it was a little clip where he's talking
about North Korea for 1999 and I never
really engaged in like heavy
conversation with him was always kind of
just you know we smiled at each other
just that you know so I never like went
out to dinner with him or anything right
yeah I was supposed to do Celebrity
Apprentice they asked me to do Celebrity
Apprentice and I had the second
integration of fear factor when fear
factor came back and like what is it
2011 or 12 or whatever it was and I just
like I don't want to do it I suppose I
don't want to be in New York for three
months I want to work on this show it
just seems kind of gross and now that I
think about it Mike's probably good move
because like what if I did it and I got
an argument with with him like was he
hated me hey and I have this [ __ ]
feud like Rosie does because Rosie
O'Donnell it seems like it consumes her
hmm like her [ __ ] Twitter feed with
it still oh my god that's all that romp
she's always asking about Trump being a
piece of [ __ ] and a loser and he tweets
about her
that's hilarious like they're grown
people yeah some more right there look
at that Oh Donald looking bad honey Wow
take time to take care of you it's only
Wednesday golf sweetie golf that's
hilarious
hahaha oh my god that's eleven how can
she say anything about anybody looking
bad
that's what's even more dumb it's
quicker she you know she's crazy I don't
know it's just like feuds like that
they're not healthy they consume you
[Applause]
[Music]